on the other hand when philosophizing by the
light of nature flows along the more even
course of sound common sense it offers at
its very best only a rhetoric of trivial truths
and if we're approached with the insignificance
of these truths it assures us in reply that
their meaning and fulfillment reside in its
heart and must surely be present in the hearts
of others too since it reckons to have said
the last word once the innocence of the heart
the purity of conscience and such like have
been mentioned these are ultimate truths to
which no exception can be taken and beyond
which nothing more can be demanded it is just
the point however that the best should not
remain in the recesses of what is inner but
should be brought out of these depths into
the light of day but it would be better by
far to spare oneself the effort of bringing
forth ultimate truths of that kind for they
have long since been available in in catechisms
or popular sayings for example it is not difficult
to grasp such vague and misleading truths
or even to show that the mind in believing
them is also aware of their very opposite
when it labors to extricate itself from the
bewilderment that sets up it falls into fresh
contradictions and may very well burst out
with the assertion that the question is settled
that so and so is the truth and that the other
views are sophistries for sophistry is a slogan
used by ordinary common sense against educated
reason just as the expression visionary dreaming
sums up once and for all what philosophy means
to those who are ignorant of it since the
man of common sense makes us appeal the feeling
to an oracle within his breast he is finished
and done with anyone who does not agree he
has only to explain that he has nothing more
to say to anyone who does not find and feel
the same in himself in other words he tramples
underfoot the roots of humanity for it is
the nature of humanity to press onward to
agreement with others human nature only really
exists in an achieved community of minds the
anti-human the merely animal consists in staying
within the sphere of feeling and being able
to communicate only at that level
the sound common sense that hegel is criticizing
in this section and continuing on to criticize
in the next section as we come to the end
of the preface of the phenomenology is something
that you could come up with synonyms for in
our own time we don't often use the term right
thinking although that was a you know a common
term in the last century right thinking means
not necessarily thinking conservatively on
the right but thinking along the lines that
a good decent person would do so in our own
contemporary society there are versions of
it where you know a person who's right thinking
thinks the way that somebody on the right
or a conservative does there's also all sorts
of ways in which right thinking is done from
the perspective of the left you know things
are simply taken for granted and of course
you can find people on on all sorts of other
extremes doing that as well hegel is using
the term common sense and this was an idea
that had become quite attractive in in the
century and a half or two centuries before
he's writing the phenomenology remember we're
separated from this work by about 200 years
and it's interesting because this is a work
that is intensely critical of modernity of
you know the processes of modernization but
it also thinks that they're in a certain sense
inescapable that the world is is been changed
radically and it's happened through things
like the dissemination of newspapers through
the creation of what jurgen habermas is called
a public sphere um in in his early work discussing
that that particular concept and and hegel
is really attuned to this we're going to see
him in the next section actually talking about
how people can avoid doing philosophy by just
getting you know the latest journals and newspapers
now that's something that's new and what does
this have to do with common sense well you
know you might think of it as sort of a lowering
of things to a certain common denominator
so that communication can take place and everybody
can have some things more or less taken for
granted it's almost like having your own little
can't or language that you communicate in
a culture or a milieu of ideas and so going
back to the right thinking idea when you have
such a milieu there are right ways to think
and there are wrong ways to think and in in
the modern period as and we're going to see
this getting played out in the phenomenology
particularly in the later sections as freedom
is spreading which is a distinctive it's not
a distinctively modern phenomenon but the
way in which freedom is spreading hegel thinks
is distinctively modern the democratization
we could say of freedom as it's spreading
people are liberating themselves and their
allegiances and their consciousness from previous
forms of authority from from institutions
to which they felt that they they owed some
deference now what comes along to replace
that well you know the enlightenment and the
the whole modern movement of thought was to
say reason but reason by itself doesn't always
get you where you want to go we've seen hegel
criticize the philosophy of the understanding
and how it ends up sort of in a type of skepticism
almost a futility a i can argue against anything
well what else could you know really satisfy
what it is that we human beings need as intellectual
creatures common sense there you've got something
that's a little bit humbler but also more
widespread it reminds me of descartes and
and his saying he didn't actually believe
this one bit when he said it but it had great
rhetorical force that you know good sense
is is so widely distributed his evidence for
that was nobody really asks for more than
they already have now that's not actually
a good argument in favor of that assertion
but there is this notion that look you don't
need to have studied philosophy or some other
technical subject you don't have to have got
underground some sort of formation you can
just be a human being and provided you can
free yourself of your biases and you know
pay attention to things with relatively clear
eyes and connect up with your fellow human
beings you can make sense out of anything
as the english say you can muddle through
it so the question is is this common sense
really adequate and hegel is looking at how
do how do people actually reason along these
these lines how do they think through it so
he says that it deploys a rhetoric of trivial
truths now when we hear the term rhetoric
we often don't don't think of everything that
it comprises in hegel's day rhetoric was still
a subject that you would you would study why
would you study it well you know in the middle
ages it was actually part of the the trivium
and it degenerated it became you know a formal
subject that that could be studied but people
were still using it and the notion was that
there was a a tradition of of inquiry and
it was primarily into figuring out um you
know certain figures of speech commonplaces
how to get emotions involved all those sorts
of things if you if you study aristotle's
rhetoric you'll see the beginnings of that
study now a rhetoric means a sort of array
of things that you can say so cicero great
rhetorician great theorist of rhetoric said
that what the the rhetor or the orator really
needs is copia that is a abundance of things
which they can can talk about you know competently
not necessarily at an expert level but at
least competently you know at least enough
to get other people to to buy into what it
is that they're saying so when we talk about
a rhetoric in this sense we don't just mean
persuasion we don't just mean rhetorical force
we mean having a bunch of common places now
what are common places i should actually put
that term up here trivial truths or commonplaces
well
let's look at some contemporary ones these
are the things that you can use in argument
or in discussion with people which is still
perhaps argument if you're trying to make
claims and advance them and defend them or
consider the appropriateness of your your
you know interlocutors claims you're really
engaged in in argument or reasoning together
um it's all good now that's a stupid thing
that people say all the time and you might
say well you know that's just a cliche it
doesn't have any meaning to it anymore no
it actually does have a lot of meaning it
has a lot of force otherwise people wouldn't
be using it in reality shows uh to you know
sort of stop conversations to um you know
move the conversation to another place it
wouldn't be happening like that if it weren't
a common place or you know does the end really
justify the means that that's you know always
poses a question and it's only asked in cases
where the interlocutor is trying to claim
that no in this case the end which is you
know supposed to be something good does not
justify the means which is supposed to be
something bad so people make recourse to these
all the time i can't make an omelet without
breaking some eggs another another cliche
another common place that people can relate
to
notice that these don't always have to be
in the form of statements they can be questions
they can be interjections they can be all
sorts of things just do it they could be imperatives
right like the nike campaign now a rhetoric
of trivial truths these places you can use
them with people who are not particularly
profound thinkers people who are just going
to operate according to common sense because
hegel's saying that's more or less what common
sense consists in this kind of inter-tissue
this you know connectivity in language and
in culture of all these different cliches
and commonplaces now when you push on that
and you say what do you actually mean by this
when you when you play the part of socrates
as he did in his own society what happens
people often can't explain i i'm not quite
sure what i did mean by that what they do
say is well i have the best intentions i i
mean something good you just have to go along
with me so there's an appeal to something
common something articulate and then there
is this sort of retreat inward
the meaning must reside in what hegel calls
the heart to hear itself right and by that
what he means is internally to the person
it's it's in my intentions it's in my mind
we don't necessarily pick heart with its romantic
connotations but the general idea is that
a person who's saying these sorts of things
they they more or less know what they mean
they're just having a hard time expressing
it and you know that's because some things
are difficult to to express um but you just
have to kind of feel your way into it you
have to feel what it is that they're saying
that's you know the greatest slang expression
you're feeling me uh as opposed to are you
understanding what i'm saying to you are you
feeling me are you having the same affective
experience as as i am or is that i want to
portray you as heaven now what's the problem
with this well there's a superficiality to
this hegel as far as the inwardness he says
um you know common sense says that the meaning
and fulfillment of these cliches reside in
its heart must surely be present in the hearts
of others too since it reconciles to the last
word once the innocence of the heart the purity
of the conscience and such like have been
mentioned and again we're talking about sort
of the phrases of right thinking humanity
within different contexts you wouldn't talk
about the purity of conscience these days
because nobody would know what you're talking
about but we have our own cliches in our own
culture that we appeal to on the same sort
of basis and then he says these are ultimate
truths to which no exception can be taken
beyond which nothing can be demanded so they're
conversation enders they say look you know
you just have to buy into it and hegel says
here's the problem
the best should not remain in the recesses
of what is inner if you can't explain it you
don't actually know it if you can't explain
it it's probably because it's really fine
spun bs that you bought into and you're trying
to get other people to buy into as well it
sounds good it may actually work in your culture
but it's not real philosophy is what hegel's
saying so he says
what we ought to be doing is trying to develop
real philosophy you don't need to do this
why do this why write a philosophy book that's
just a bunch of aphorisms why write self-help
books why write leadership books why write
so many of these things that actually you
know if you were going to investigate the
topic you would realize there there's a lot
of work that has to be done here if it's going
to be genuine rigorous philosophy or science
but it's really easy to write a book that
makes people feel okay provided they don't
think about it too much provided they think
that they're thinking but they're not really
thinking deeply about it as a matter of fact
like i put here all of this can already be
found available it's already there for you
you don't need to reinvent that wheel hegel
talks about catechisms again we don't you
know not a term that we really use unless
we're doing religious instruction but we have
all sorts of other things listicles great
example uh you know we have all these articles
all these blog posts about you know what you
should be doing in the workplace and how to
improve your life and how to unscrew up your
relationships and you know anything from spirituality
to neuroscience to whether we should you know
try to colonize mars or not and you can put
it all into a nice easy to read bullet point
form well that's exactly what hagel's talking
about here as what common sense tries to put
over as being philosophy and again you know
he doesn't have a problem with common sense
as such he doesn't have a problem with rhetoric
what he has is a problem with this pretending
to be genuine philosophy so he says you know
when you grasp try to grasp these vague and
misleading truths or show that the mind believing
in them is also aware of their very opposite
that is when you're doing dialectical philosophy
it gets them all confused so to common sense
real philosophy dialectical philosophy appears
to be sophistry why because the sophist is
the person who can argue on both sides and
can make the weaker argument appear stronger
and what appears to be weaker to the to the
crowd to the man of common sense to the person
who's you know only got this going for them
only has practice in that the argument that
appears stronger to them may not actually
be the stronger argument as a matter of fact
the whole progression of the dialectic that
hegel is turning out in this book is a case
where what what is the stronger argument for
a while turns out to have yet a stronger rival
that it's displaced by and then you know the
aufka haebong takes place the sublation or
the transcending of it um sophistry like he
says is a slogan used by ordinary common sense
against educated reason just as the expression
visionary dreaming sums up once and for all
what philosophy means to those who are ignorant
of it um will philosophy be able to convince
these people probably not it does have the
last laugh in that they don't really know
what they're doing and they're not going to
remain within the grand stream of humanity
quite you know interesting to read old popular
magazines from just half a century ago and
to remark on what they took to be common wisdom
and how far we have moved away from that and
then do that with with stuff later you know
further back and now transpose that into our
own time and think about 99 of the stuff that
we actually read in popular magazines and
newspapers on the internet that we see on
tv and think you know a lot of that is stuff
where the very assumptions that are built
into it are things that other people are going
to so to speak [__] on later on now what
does hagel conclude with here he says in a
sense this common sense attitude it looks
like it's being you know very homey and you
know humble and reaching out to the other
but it's actually kind of anti-human how so
because it just appeals to feeling and by
merely appealing to feeling rather than our
intellects it appears to our it appeals to
our intellect in a superficial way in a way
that works so long as you don't push it very
far but when the intellect actually gets some
traction and starts you know pumping away
it outstrips common sense
to be human to be genuinely human means to
be able to be elevated out of the realm of
merely feeling and mere repetition of catchphrases
and cliches or even you know puttering around
bricolage as the postmodernist like to say
with that sort of thing humanity involves
genuine communication this seems to be communication
but it's not authentic communication authentic
communication requires that you try to attain
agreement with others not that you take it
as a starting point so he says it is the nature
of humanity to press onward to agreement with
others not something that you just take as
you know we already have agreement and we're
going to work on the basis that agreement
agreement is something that comes down the
line says human nature only really exists
in an achieved community of minds for us to
know what human nature really is the implication
here is for us to do so with others in a community
not of bodies not of just hanging out next
to each other not of world of warcraft or
you know playing music together or being in
the same university or anything like that
but a community of minds a community in which
people are engaging with each other they can
be engaging in terms of music gaming all sorts
of other things cooking even but what's what's
necessary as an element is something doesn't
have to be called philosophy but something
that plays the role of philosophy lacking
that we don't have a genuine community of
minds we have a community of interest you
might say but not a community of minds and
so this is what we're trying to attain and
in the process we're going to get to know
these others but that's a story for another
time
should anyone ask for a royal road to science
there is no more easy going way than to rely
on sound common sense and for the rest in
order to keep up with the times and with advances
in philosophy to read reviews of philosophical
works perhaps even to read their preferences
and first paragraphs for these preliminary
pages give the general principles on which
everything turns on the reviews as well as
providing historical accounts also provide
the critical appraisal which being a judgment
stands high above the work judged this common
road can be taken in casual dress but the
high sense for the eternal the holy the infinite
strides along in the robes of a high priest
on a road that is from the first no road but
has immediate being as its center the genius
of profound original ideas and lofty flashes
of inspiration but just as profundity of this
kind still does not reveal the source of essential
being so too these skyrockets of inspiration
are not yet the emperian true thoughts and
scientific insight are only to be won through
the labor of the notion only the notion can
produce the universality of knowledge which
is neither common vagueness nor the inadequacy
of ordinary common sense but a fully developed
perfected cognition not the uncommon universality
of a reason whose talents have been ruined
by indolence and the conceit of genius but
a truth ripened to its properly matured form
so as to be capable of being the property
of all self-conscious reason
in section 70 hegel is continuing his criticisms
of common sense and he's going to draw them
to to a close and then we'll take it up again
much later in the phenomenology he's also
engaging in a little bit of play and humor
that i want to call your attention to as he's
doing this he talks about the royal road to
science and let's remember of course when
he's talking about science he's not just talking
about you know people in lab coats and playing
with chemicals or people putting other people
in mris or let alone journals about science
that sort of thing he's talking about a systematic
developed conception of things that not only
takes into account the things that we observe
and act upon and understand but also ourselves
our role in the process and the sweep of history
you know human development and where we fit
into that so you know it's science is not
something without a past and a future and
opportunities of the present so the royal
road to science what would the royal road
be today we would call it the interstate or
you know whatever the equivalent is in other
countries here in the united states it's the
interstate these these massive highways that
were built ultimately you know to transport
military materials but they've been used just
incredibly for commercial traffic and even
you know leisure traffic a royal road is one
which not necessarily providing a shortcut
but the straightest clearest most unimpeded
path to where it is that you want to go so
for example freud on the interpretation of
dreams he's going to use that same metaphor
of the royal road dreams are the royal road
to the unconscious if you want if you want
to understand the unconscious it's not as
if you can't do it by other means you can
observe the the patient you can do free association
but dreams are the best way into it so what
is hegel trying to get at here he's saying
that for for many people in his contemporary
culture there's a royal road to science a
shorter path a straighter path and what is
it consistent he says sound common sense rely
on that and for the rest because you need
some supplement sound common sense won't give
you everything you need we've already seen
some of the problems with it you can supplement
it by reading what a wonderful world we live
in i mean think about how this would play
out in our contemporary society with respect
to education is available everywhere on the
internet well yes and no i mean this is a
great example right here you can watch videos
of this ultimately you probably do need to
read and think about hegel because you're
not going to get it all from watching me up
in front of the chalkboard or sitting in my
chair you know reading from the text that's
not the same thing as you putting in the work
to to make hegel your own to enter into a
conversation with him i'm just sort of an
interpreter or translator or you know um think
of the guy who's introducing you at the party
hey i want i want you to get to know this
guy over here um
what what's the supplementing going on here
so hegel talks about two things but we could
expand this to include all sorts of other
ideas as well he talks about if you want to
know what's going on in philosophy if you
want to know what was really important just
read reviews of the articles read reviews
of the work gee don't read kant's critique
of pure reason why spend all that time on
that my god you'll you just destroy your mind
trying to figure out what he's saying just
read somebody's review that'll tell you the
most important stuff in it and it'll also
help you out because it'll tell you what's
right in it and what's wrong in it you don't
have to think that out for yourself you don't
have to figure all that for you know on your
own you know you've got professionals to handle
that sort of thing just like you know why
do you need to worry about what you eat at
a restaurant you just read what the restaurant
critics say about the place you know what's
good on the menu what's not or you know you
want a more personal thing ask your your server
ask the chef what do you recommend tonight
i can't really trust my own taste because
it's not developed i've put in the work to
do it i'm going to rely on somebody else's
reviews well i mean you can do that and i'm
not saying that reviews are not useful at
all oftentimes uh reviewers may if they're
very good call attention to things that the
um philosopher if we want to think about movies
you know the filmmaker or the writer himself
or herself didn't actually catch because when
we produce things there's often a lot more
involved than we're consciously aware of but
a review does not substitute for the work
does it so hegel goes a little bit further
you know if you're going to read the work
just read like you know the first couple chapters
or maybe just a preface you can look at the
table of contents that'll tell you if it's
worth reading or not it'll tell you what it's
about maybe look at the index
i've seen people do this actually in determining
whether they should read a book or not a book
of secondary literature let me look at the
index and see if it cites the people that
i'm interested in hearing about and okay there's
about eight citations of aristotle there must
be a pretty good book well you don't know
that right i mean this is quite silly so he
says um these preliminary pages give the general
principles on which everything turns and the
reviews as well as providing historical accounts
so you know where things fit in you know this
is one of the beefs i have with people who
always want to say oh i love durant's story
and philosophy yeah it is a good story it's
not an accurate story in every respect a lot
of these secondary works are you know pretty
one-sided that they got interested in this
over here and this over here and that's what
they wrote about then they totally ignored
the other stuff over here that's a little
bit more important good secondary literature
is a bit more balanced than that providing
critical appraisal which being a judgment
stands high above the work judged so you know
when you're when you're reading a major work
of philosophy you don't want to just take
it for granted you don't want to read descartes
and say well you know descartes he's an important
guy so he must be right you do want to form
your own judgments about it but you want to
form your own judgments you don't necessarily
just want to import them from whoever happens
to be an influential philosopher at the time
or you know pick some secondary work um you
know there's a lot of great descartes scholars
who are worth reading but you want to actually
assess their judgments on your own which means
you actually need to read the work you actually
need to engage descartes uh yourself if you
want to be able to appreciate what they're
saying about it i realize that sounds like
an awful lot of work now he says something
else here that's kind of funny so he talks
about the high sense for and he's got a bunch
of you know things here talks about the the
eternal the holy the infinite now again those
were the sort of things that that um people
talked about a lot in hegel's time we don't
have quite so much talk about those now but
we have our own the dot dot dots that people
are constantly on about like the singularity
what's going to happen with the singularity
or neuroscience or um you know the democracy
agenda that one's pretty much in the tank
now after what's happened in the middle east
over the last 10 years but you get the idea
liberation um overcoming of of of this overcoming
of that it seems like you can't become a philosopher
by the way and there's a total digression
you can't become a philosopher without coining
a few catchphrases deconstruction the other
everybody talks about the other right um externalism
which means a million different things in
a million different contexts but like he's
talking about the high sense for these you
know big ideas big catchphrases strides along
the road in the robes of a high priest now
notice he's not saying the eternal is walking
down the road in the robes behind priests
he's saying this kind of feeling for it this
kind of i'm one of the people who who does
this kind of thing and boy if you go to philosophy
conferences you'll see plenty of people like
this uh who who are you know they think that
they're really hot stuff because they talk
about this particular thing or go to a cultural
studies conference or go to well just watch
ted at you know watch ted talks a lot of these
people are so you know full of the eternal
full of neuroscience full of whatever that
um they really think that they you know they've
got the thing the thumb on the pulse um now
here's where it gets really interesting hegel
like draws everything to a grinding halt and
he says that's not a road
this isn't actually a road to anything it's
just like he says immediate being as its center
it takes the genius of profound original ideas
and lofty flashes of inspiration and he says
that's all real nice but it's just smoke and
mirrors it's not really giving you essential
being it talks about these skyrockets of inspiration
are not yet the imperium they're not yet the
heavens the what we want to see true thoughts
and scientific insight are only to be won
through something else something else that
hegel wants to direct us to only this can
produce the universality of knowledge which
is neither common vagueness nor the inadequacy
of only ordinary common sense but a fully
developed perfected perfected means brought
to its fulfillment cognition not the uncommon
universality of a reason whose talents have
been ruined by indolence and the conceit of
genius influence means laziness laying around
just reading reviews instead of actually doing
the work just watching you know uh simplified
videos on things rather than actually reading
the text and thinking about them
relying on spark notes and wikipedia that
sort of thing a troop a truth ripened to its
properly matured form so as to be capable
of being the property of all self-conscious
reason that's what we're aiming at what's
required for that one word i've been leaving
out here
what hegel is called what's translated here
as the notion the griff the concept we've
seen a lot about this we'll see a lot more
about this but this is something that goes
beyond mere common sense beyond merely you
know reading summaries or schemas of of things
and actually goes to if we want to use uh
you know husserl's language to the things
themselves and doesn't just like go to them
and like look at them but grapples with them
tries to make them their own tries to think
about what's my role in relation to this including
other things being other persons including
other things being historical errors being
great concepts like freedom or you know necessity
or progress so that's what hegel offers instead
of this rather you know seductive high road
that turns out not to be a road at all but
really just a cul-de-sac